mein name ist herzlich willkommen wir
heute meine lieben freunde zu einer
neuen episode ebay fels ich würde sagen
wir verlieren gar nicht lange zeit und
fangen direkt mit dem ersten ebay feld
und zwar verschenkt hier jemand seinen
philips fernseher mit leichten
gebrauchsspuren und einem fernseher mit
leichten gebrauchsspuren stellt man sich
jetzt gleich so ein gerät vor mit einem
kleinen kratzer einer ecke oder mit ein
bisschen staubte an der einen seite
unter dem glas aber nein dieser
fernseher hier verschenkt wird sieht so
aus dicker das sieht aus als wenn er
irgendwie pappe hinter aber naja machen
wir weiter mit dem nächsten die befehle
und zwar verkauft dort jemand wird 299
euro eine lacoste banane erste und
letzte generation neu und ungeöffnet und
ja also halt eine lacoste banane
beim nächsten die bfl frag ich mich
wirklich gar nichts mehr ruft kurz also
hier verkauft jemand den furz einer kuh
eingefangen einem true fruits glas
also seine kreativität muss man erst mal
haben dass jetzt der nächste bielefeld
und zwar seht ihr schon oben kaum
benutzt roller skates beziehungsweise
rollstuhl verkauft er für 150 euro der
preis ist allerdings verhandelbar und
das foto ist das hier
[Musik]
ja also wer würde nicht gern mit diesen
rollerblades rumfahren beim nächsten die
dfl verkauft jemand aus berlin einen
erschöpften stuhl für 65 euro und ihr
fragt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich halo
kann was ist eine erschöpfte schulen nun
ja das frage ich mich auch
beziehungsweise habe ich mich gefragt
bis ich diese aus wie ein gerupftes
hühnchen oder sowas
aber meine lieben freunde das war bisher
alles nur so angebots fans die ich euch
gezeigt habe dass heißt jetzt zeige ich
euch zum ersten mal in der heutigen
folge einen chat verlauf und zwar zu
diesem produkt eine man cher es 600
elektro roller elektroscooter ganz kurze
vorgeschichte und zwar möchte eine
person dieses guter kaufen allerdings
nur wenn die personen später verkauft
auch einen kaufbeleg dafür hat weil die
person hat denke ich dass da irgendwie
abgezogen wurde und wenn ich ihnen jetzt
kaufe komme ich irgendwie in
polizeiliche probleme also das ist ein
bisschen die vorgeschichte und die
person jesu scooter kaufen möchte hat
jetzt nach dem kaufbeleg gefragt und
daraufhin erwidert der verkäufer java
scheiße aufkauf voran dass das jetzt
ebay und nicht mediamarkt ich brauche
keinen kaufbeleg du merkst mit warum
hast du den dann ebay weiß doch jeder
hans und franz dass nicht jeder bei ebay
kaufbeleg hat kauft billig billig billig
dann kaufte ein scheiß kauf will ich
raus für den kauf fällig auch ein
kaufbeleg alter mein roller ist lich
geklaut vielen dank für die freundliche
und ausführliche antwort sie haben mich
überzeugt ich kaufe den roller ja das
ist via ebay kleinanzeigen at its best
halo ist die wohnung hellhörig das wäre
extrem wichtig zu wissen da ich rege
mich sich frauen besucht habe und in
meiner jetzigen wohnung beschweren sich
die nachbarn einfach zu oft liebe grüße
als klassiker der sude frauenheld es
auch heute wieder am start hause eine
samsung galaxy s 4 verhandelbar aus 2 4
939 flensburg art samsung zustand
gebrauchtes her klingt das komplett nach
einem normalen ebay angebot allerdings
hat die beschreibung also ich weiß nicht
wie man so viele recht schnell wieder
bei so wenig wörter machen kann guten
zustand hatte magath erst sonst
ist er von zion war alles klar der ja
ich weiß nicht was du mir mitteilen
wollen es aber ich finde dass ihr
empfehlen anstelle eines tauschgeschäfts
mit einem samsung galaxy s 4 bei diesen
liebefeld seht ihr schon geht es um eine
tüte goldbären allerdings nicht meine
normale tüte goldbären sondern um eine
haribo tüte mit nur zwei gummibärchen
und der verkauf dieser tüte mit nur zwei
küsschen für entspannte 20 euro ja da
für dich direkt zuschlagen
bei diesen die bfl verkauft eine person
ein wasserbett und zwar schreibt ein
möglicher käufer hallo hätte interesse
wie es ist mit geschlechtsverkehr bei
der beet gratis lieferung hallo meine
frau jetzt schwanger gratis abholung
dann kein interesse
glückwünsch was haben manche leute
geraucht dass sie so schlecht und so
wenig von der deutschen sprache
beherrschen das ist ja nicht mehr normal
danke haye ist made in germany
ok letzter preis bitte 1450 weil die
reifen sind echt toll
sie werden vom bordstein getroffen als
taktiker einfach mal entspannt vom
bordstein getroffen das hier ist das
nächste produkt das auf ebay verkauft
werde ich weiß nicht genau was es ist
auf der einen seite sieht irgendwie aus
wie eine kleine schraube allerdings
können sie auf der anderen seite auch
wenn man das ganze ein bisschen von
weiter weg betrachtet auch ein
heizungsregler seien allerdings schreibt
auf jeden fall die person in die
beschreibung dreck fressen für 25 euro
also keine ahnung wo das eine drag
fresse ist aber okay ich würde auf jeden
fall kaufen wollen dann das hier ist das
nächste ebay angebot und dass es geht
und zwar kann man schon unschwer
erkennen dass es ein staubsauger kopf
ist beziehungsweise einen staubsauger
bürste allerdings schreibt die person
nicht irgendwie hey das ist eine dyson
staubsauger böse in den titel des
angebots sondern er schreibt teyssen
turbo brüste für 40 euro
ja ich meine frau hätte nicht gern turbo
brüste machen allerdings direkt weiter
mit dem nächsten ebay verlor zwar geht
es darum einen ikea schreibt sich mit
glasplatte und zwar schreibt ein
potenzieller käufer geil haha ich auch
und darauf erwidert allerdings der
verkäufer muss mich für heute doch
entschuldigen brauchen den tisch noch
mal zum saufen als ablage aber morgen
würde gehen hahahaha
hahahaha allerdings meine lieben freunde
zu dem ebay ferien ihr wahrscheinlich
auch schon im fall des heutigen videos
gesehen hat und auch im titel meines
heutigen videos gelesen hat und zwar
verkauft jemand seine airports
allerdings keine richtigen airports
sagte aktiv und verkauft sie als apple
airports bis 60 euro schreibt doch so
daneben 70 euro durchgestrichen letztes
sonderangebot die amis können einige
leute auf ebay ein effekt ist jedes mal
aufs neue
alles klar wir spielen texturen wenn ich
gewinne bekomme ich es für zehn euro
inklusive versand wenn du gewinnst
gewichtet 20 euro ohne versand deal was
gibt mir die sicherheit dass du auch
dann 20 euro zahlt was passiert bei
unentschieden unentschieden gleich neue
runde so was lustiges habe ich auf
kleiner zeigt noch nie gehört wer fängt
an also die spielen tic tac toe und
handeln damit den preis für ein produkt
aus dann wäre ich jetzt auf jeden fall
unten eingeblendet dass er geschrieben
hat fangen sie an der schickt eine
vorlage die man die ganze zeit gespielt
und am ende hat die rechte personen
gewonnen
die linke personen schreibt noch nicht
dann schreibt er jetzt aber scheiße rief
bombe
die klassische reform geht die man dann
halt will hier verkauft jemand auf ebay
dieses wunderschöne blaue kleid man
denkt jetzt im ersten moment eventuell
sogar das angebot nun ja der titel von
dem ebay angebot ist cocktailkleid für
20 euro ich glaube die person meinte
cocktailkleid auch dir würde ich das
hier empfehlen an der stelle
wenn ich ziemlich taktlos dass ich den
leuten die ganze zeiten duden nahelegen
vielleicht haben sie sich einfach
verschrieben was ist taktlos überhaupt
für ein komisches wort das er ist auf
jeden fall der nächste ebay felder und
mercedes schon oben wird sinkt bereit
für alles ein euro ebay kostenlos
einfach lokal verändern zeigen logo auf
jeden fall art reinigungsservice also
ein unternehmen und bisher seine person
bietet hier einen reinigungsservice an
das lustige an dem angebot ist
allerdings die beschreibung und zwar
wittert geschrieben hallo wir werfen
wegräumen vom keller auf dem dachboden
was auch immer der besuch für ein
angebot ist kostenlos bitte schreibe
käsekuchen freudig über meine angebote
bitte schreibe käsekuchen leute bitte
schreibe käsekuchen
hier verkauft die dann vom 7 und ein
interessent fragt hallo wie ist der
zustand des iphones außerdem
interessiert mich die akkukapazität zu
finden unter einstellungen batterie
maximale kapazität blabla im voraus
vielen dank für die beantwortung meiner
fragen gruß thomas sind sie thomas die
lokomotive alles klassiker haben wir nun
allerdings zu 540 hintereinander
vorlesen möchte wurden nicht unbedingt
auf dem einen fall geht sondern wo ein
personen einen reim mit dem angeboten
namen gemacht haben das war ein
schwieriger satz fallen auf jeden fall
an mit diesem hier rosen sind rot im
dunkeln pinkeln kann ich nicht da ich
viel unterwegs bin kaufe ich ein globus
mit licht gut machen wir weiter mit dem
nächsten und zwar rosen sind rot meine
belegten brote sind immer lecker
deswegen nennt man meine küche auch das
ist handywecker beruhigt
wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten
großen sind rote die hohen mieten lasst
ihr euch nicht bieten dann kommt zu mir
ich habe eine günstige zwei zentimeter
wurden
[Musik]
ich dass die gruppe gedroht ich mag
keine götter darum zu verschenken
gebrauchte ein gewohnt hatte
[Musik]
manchmal an den schweinen und nicht
leute ja gut der letzte rose sind rot
ich mag es mich zu verdrängen deshalb
übel herzliche kauders überschritten und
damit meine lieben freunde würde ich ihr
heutiger wieso die ebay fans auch
beenden obwohl ein habe ich noch einen
habe ich noch der beschreibt mich
nämlich zu 1000% ich hätte interesse
wenn sie es mir kostenlos senden warum
sollte ich das kostenlos tun nein danke
wieviel möchten sie ich habe kein geld
aber will das haben und der letzte satz
er beschreibt mein komplettes leben ich
habe kein geld aber ich will trotzdem
tolle dinge haben anderer stelle will
ich jetzt aber wirklich das heutige
video beenden meine lieben freunde wenn
ihr bock auf einen weiteren teil ebay
feld habe dann schreibt mir das gern und
in die kommentare las einen daumen hoch
beim video a und abonniert main kanal
weil es noch kein teil der luxus als
alles andere wäre taktlos
[Musik]